it's coming up december 26th to the 31st
we will be in texas missouri and ohio go
get your tickets end the year with us
co-headlining doing stand-up comedy it's
going to be fun it's going to be great
go to salvolcanocomedy.com or
christiecomedy.com is going to be great
and then also babe also babe you know
what i just put on sale today what's
that oh actually yesterday is i'm coming
to chicago i'm doing the chicago theater
use the pre-sale code chaos the pre-sale
is happening right now at christy
comedy.com the chicago theater march
12th baby okay and here we go for me i
gotta call out two dates san diego on
january 21st at the magnolia theater and
los angeles january 22nd at the wilton
theater i have not headlined in los
angeles yet it's gonna be a real special
show there's gonna be some surprise
guests there from the la area it's gonna
be a lot of fun go see that one last
thing to call out yeah we're both
playing the agora theater in cleveland
oh my god when are you going to be there
i'm going to be there on january 16th
babe yes and i'm going to be there in
march yes
so uh yeah so you'll be there
60 days after me i'm going to leave you
a joint underneath one of the seats i'm
going to tape it to one of these come to
ball shows at the igor theater if you
don't i'll kill your loved ones
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe
[Music]
first of all because a lot of people
have been saying over the last year
you've seen the comments i've seen the
comments pimp sees the comments we see
the comments we see the comments about
how it's been divided some people love
your hair some people loved your hair
some people didn't love your hair yeah i
don't slip backward up no no no no no
the way you have it right now yeah it's
like a hollywood leading actor
like look like it's like it's like
beautiful
it's like the hair did you go through
that phase growing out your hair i don't
remember it but did you go through that
phase where like it was kind of like
because you went from a shave i'm in
that phase all the time my hair is too
long too short well i never ever do it
and so today
i did it with like a blow dryer and
product which is how they do it when i
leave the
hair cutting place right but i never can
recreate it at home but i did have help
do you do you feel like at any point
you'll go back to a normal like like say
shaved on the side yes you are going to
do that i i was tempted the last few
times that i was there oh wow i love but
but do you agree pimp do you like his
hair like that love it i think
this would never be
on me if it wasn't for the quarantine
because i grew up because no one could
get haircuts and then i said i haven't
had hair like this in 20 years let me
just grow it a little bit because
normally your hair would just be like
mine like you would shave it on the
sides every three weeks most yes right
yes i would get it touched up right i
think i'm gonna go back i just you know
what it is i just i'm keeping it maybe
through the winter because i like the
way it looks when i put on like a wool
cap or a hat it kind of like flips out
it feels like a winter feel yeah and
even after the winter i'm gonna just
shave this off like you're gonna go down
to your level again i'm going i've made
a decision i've made two decisions we
talked about this on my on my podcast to
chrissy chaos podcast last week i've
made two decisions one i'm gonna go from
i'm right now 241 pounds i'm going down
to 201 pounds by uh june 24th or i will
amputate my right or left hand
a hand can't i'm gonna i know you're
gonna say i honestly you've got to
amputate a hand or a foot what do you do
i say foot i say foot you got to do foot
look how many people i see
how many people i see with the um the
bar they might have had an
accident or been in the and they had
they get cut off at the knee they had
the bar with the fake foot they they
they're doing every i mean it's they're
in the olympia i mean there's no i mean
look it's terrible right but if i had to
choose one i go foot i think you got
foot i would go for two i made the
choice i made the decision on the pando
to say hand and this was
in retrospect i wish i would have done
it here because then you would have
correctly said do foot and foot i
wouldn't be losing sleep over yeah at
night but now it's i would but yeah so
you're committed now
they make good fake hands now though
they do yeah prosthetics are you might
have
a animatronic a robotic hand underneath
their foot
right yeah although that's probably
that's from star wars
[Laughter]
you might have we might have a star wars
type thing right where if you lose a
limb nowadays you might not even be able
to tell anymore because of the did you
see um ex machina yes i did i kept
calling it x mashina but it's ax machina
i i think it's marketing because i've
heard it but i think i might have called
the next machine at first i don't know
the second there's the first thing is
241-201 the second thing i've committed
to doing is growing out my hair and
i we found a bar
what style i'm gonna similar to
i don't want to say similar to yours but
grow it out with just getting shape ups
and trimming up the beard and cutting it
but growing it out on the sides and in
the back because i always i'm very
there's two things that i'm not
comfortable with on my body okay one my
hips
okay don't lie two
the back of my head every time i see a
picture of the back of my head
i have a cinder block
fat back of the head but i feel like
have you know if you don't like the back
your head either have you seen pictures
of the back your head now with more hair
do you like it more with more hair i
like it i like it more yeah because it
covers up the head because it's usually
shave tight and i don't like it i have a
fred flintstone head i have like a you
know i see how i have this line right
here because it's hard for me to see
because i'm wearing purple sunglasses i
understand that yeah there's like a
crease eventually you get like crease
like you have creases in your forehead
over here i have a crease
on the back of my head
so like i hate it because it like it
even when you shave it it looks like i
have a crease you know what's crazy i
have never i've known you how long have
you been eight years now uh at least
never once in my life of and i've looked
at your face many many times in in
personally with you and on the internet
i've never ever ever noticed that crease
in between your eyes i hated it you just
said i've never been doing this for a
long time that's all i could see have
you ever noticed a crease i've never in
my life but you know now you're not
going to stop now i could see salsa
vagina yeah
you're going gonna see it all the time
now but i love but you know what doesn't
really bother me it's just that when i
look in pictures i'm always like god
damn it how do i get that out
i don't think i i think that's what
people do the talks the bow you can't do
both i'm not doing both i don't want to
have you seen bad botox it's great yeah
pull it up baby hold it up there i see
botox bad botox bad box bathtubs
oh there it is yeah i mean the girl's
eye fell out yeah we got bad [ __ ] going
on what have you ever seen a woman's
butt implants fall out
i haven't you've seen them fall out like
a like a mini kangaroo out of a pouch
that'll kill you that'll kill you a bad
abundant plan will kill you how does a
bunny implant fall out if it comes out
the [ __ ] yes see see it just pops out
that'll kill you what do you mean oh
you can't show this to the fans do you
want to describe it oh you can't i mean
will we just show this ladies people
watch dr pimple papa md
i got to be honest with you ladies
fellas uh ladies fellas
ladies
fellas i don't if you got real hair real
fingernails if you got a job you're
going to school and you're going to
dance
make some noise
[Music]
um i don't care for a fake ass
fake boobs even i don't
okay i'll say this
but i i like a fake butt less than i
like fake boobs i don't care either you
know when did fake butts start have they
been around forever because i only heard
about fake butts like maybe five years
ago or so and now a fake butt i think is
as common as fake boobs there is you you
can never ever you don't know
now if it's a if it's a fake butt or
boobs what would it button plants
started in 1969 that's hilarious
oh my god oh
so when you said it just falls out what
i didn't realize is there's an incision
on the left or the thigh here and the
one that fell out the lady her her skin
just ripped open
you saw that right and then it just just
i guess what what is it what is the fake
part of the ass is it silicone like the
breasts i think it's gotta be silicon
when it first started it says here that
it was
and now it's slowly morphing into let's
see what it's morphing what is it
yeah i have every celebrity have that
like everyone that has an ass that right
everybody has it right everybody from
you know
singers to actresses that have that kind
of because also now that ass is
everywhere and i never saw that ass in
the past i never saw that ass yeah if
that ass is just coming out and i ain't
never seen it it's because you got a
fake ass i ain't never seen that ass in
the past now i'd be seeing that ass all
the time i'll be seeing that everybody i
know got that ass yo let me ask you this
yeah
is it out of the realm of possibility
ask me i'm going to ask you a question
right now
you got to answer me honestly sure do
you
do you think let's say i mean the final
finale i mean like a david blaine event
i mean you're talking about you can make
real money doing this the final final in
practical jokers would you consider uh
if you lost getting ass implants that
you had to wear for a year okay i will
tell you that we already were going to
give mer tits
and we can open
surgeries
we've been talking about this for a
couple of years and for this one some of
them you have to
tell him you can't just knock him out
chloroform him and surprise him
so we we said because it is surgery he
has to elect and we said look dude we
think this would be an amazing amazing
idea
if we can give you implants but then
take them out after like you had to wear
them for like a week or something would
you do it and i think tamar's credit i
think he said yes oh my god shout out
mark wow yeah although i don't know it's
a lot of recovery he doesn't have the
natural
like
uh doesn't a woman have the natural
pocket there for the breast to go i mean
it would be a brutal week yeah i love
that i love that myrrh would consider
getting tit implants and not hair
implants
[Laughter]
shout out um okay here we go so butt
augmentation goes mainstream nearly 10
000 americans augmented their booties
last year a 16 increase from 2012 wow
with kim k and her cohorts redefining
standards of booty beauty it's likely to
keep increasing
well what what year is this article from
nobody because it says
2014. that's okay that was 2014 they had
10 000. they went up 16 to 2012. right
now i got to be honest i think every
single person alive has a button plan
i'm going to go my mother probably has
it my mother probably has it seriously
i'm gonna go home today and ask the
mother of my children and say do you
have a butt implant tell me the truth
this is crazy in 2018 it jumped to 24
000 implants wow that's big
surging 19
now if you're a plastic surge right and
you've never done an ass before and all
of a sudden it's the hot [ __ ] what are
you are you going are you taking like a
like a learning annex class real quick
like how are you how are you
backtracking to ask when you never do
that it has to be a continuing education
course
for plastic surgeons that you could just
take butt implant because it's got
because here's the thing here's the
thing you have to be an insanely
talented surgeon to do that right
because if you mess up you could you
could kill somebody with a butt implant
you could kill people why can you kill
people with a butt implant though it
feels like it's in an area that's not
not that bad because if it leaks into
your blood you get sepsis blood
infection dead so what is it that leaks
into your blood i think i think whatever
the uh i heard
that butt implants when you take when
you take fat from another part of your
body and shoot your own fat into your
own ass
but now we're saying like just like
implants for the breasts there's literal
butt implants no started that way okay
can you have to get gum implants my
dentist said
they have to cut you ready for this you
want to know for this you want a modern
torture
at the at the dental uh dentist um that
i go to
they say i have to get something called
i think it's called a gum resection they
want to cut off skin from the roof of my
mouth and add more gums to my teeth
because my gums are receding i was like
absolutely [ __ ]
feel like we could do it now if you're
cool with it yeah i was like
no thanks i was like wouldn't that hurt
after the
you know anesthesia wears off they're
like yeah you people patients are
usually in significant amount of pain
i'm like why are you doing it
how do you know your gums are receding i
because i don't know the dentist told me
he said that your gums are receding and
i said but you went to a new dentist yes
so he hadn't seen your gums prior that's
what i said oh he's not probably doing
it on site there's probably a telltale
sign in there right there's probably a
telltale sign up in your grill he said
and i said to him i said what's the
alternative he said your gums will
continue continuous uh continually
recede and so your teeth probably fallen
i said what year would my teeth fall out
roughly said you got about another 20
years i said i'll take it in 20 years
who cares if i have teeth or not i'll be
in my late 50s it won't matter the next
time i go to the dentist i'm going to be
like can you please tell me if my gums
are receding yeah my god i haven't even
heard of this
and you know what i do i'm bad but when
i brush i'm drunk by the way i have are
you drunk
i'm drinking a vodka lacroix yeah
when i do the brush at home let me tell
you at home i use the uh well i use uh
the people that sponsor us well equip
yeah
and uh
before i got equipped i have a whole
bunch of toothbrushes hey babe yeah
whole bunch of but i go like
hard even right at the gum because you
know you know what you get in when you
floss too yeah which i don't do as much
as i should and i haven't my whole life
i never knew i was supposed to lose
though my whole life and everybody was
supposed to walk through floors no i
only started flossing when the doctor
told me my gums were receding and now i
do the water pick i i i do the water
pick yes yeah do you think the gum the
water pick is a substitute for the for
the floss i was told that it's it's it's
it's a it's a coin flip water pick a
dental floss is that right sticky points
if so then i'm okay then i'm better than
i thought because i thought it wasn't a
substitute
i mean listen
i'm literally spraying water at my teeth
i'd have to yeah but 400 miles an hour i
know close range do you floss a water
pick no
most people don't and so they told me at
one point back when oh you don't floss
you're gonna lose all your teeth and i
was like that's when i bought the water
pick because i can't floss i can't floss
i hate it bad news chris uh oh a water
pit can help remove food particles from
your teeth it might help reduce bleeding
and gum disease but it isn't generally
considered a substitute for brushing and
flossing it doesn't generally remove
visible film and plaque on your teeth
but can
aid in reduction of bacteria even below
the gum line well from going from
absolutely nothing where my gums are
receding yeah like you know
i i i think at least water picking at
least it's something well this is what
i'm getting at i've been shooting water
at a high speed at my choppers for like
for like five years i'm wondering if i'm
blasting my own gums back you might be
self-fulfilling prof might be doing it
so what is a water pick you like power
washing it's like yeah
it's a power washer for your [ __ ]
chicklets that's what you do you power
wash your teeth you power wash your
teeth
you know and i i'm wondering i'm i'm
it's like turning the hose on it yeah
i'm wondering if i'm shooting pushing my
own gums back yeah you got me scared
about gums well then do you do that in
the morning
uh whenever i brush i do yeah i do i do
well no that's when i supposed to do it
and when i do it that's when i do it but
do i forget to do i not do it i usually
don't do it
like i'll go get on a kick i'll do it
every day for a week and then we'll do
it for like a month
right so i'm going to do it tonight
very inconsistent i'm i'm so
inconsistent with the flushing the bra
the frosting the flushing and the brush
march 12th chicago theater pre-sale code
happening right now use the pre-sell
code chaos christy comedy.com chicago
i'm coming baby
hey while you're in chicago come see me
at the vic that's on sale right now what
date is you are you uh
i wish i knew ah just google i think
it's the february 28th no february 28th
we're doing a college gig together it's
the 29th i think
ah
oh damn i i was gonna see if you wanted
to drive to boston together but i guess
i won't can't i'm gonna fly in whatever
what does it say
oh salvano february 27th 20th you were
right okay okay so okay vic i'll be
there the 27th the first show's almost
uh it's almost sold out we might be
adding more so get your tickets right
look at that we're doing very close time
maybe i'll go to the vic and then you
come to chicago theater let's do let's
do back-to-back weekends in chicago
you and i i would love to do that you
want to do that but i'm aware they'll
become before i'm away every weekend on
tour in january and february
hello fresh is when we don't even need
practice for we don't have to read
through we just love it we know it it's
america's number one meal kid it's
america's number one meal kit and they
send it right to your door and you could
pick what you want uh or you could take
a positive method or you can pick there
no no you can pick what you want i use
it okay i use it every week of course
now guess what they have desserts i've
been getting the same one though so i
don't know if if i could i forgot if i
get bigger well we used to talk about
the pumpkin cinnamon rolls that they had
but now they have desserts they have
this like vanilla delight cheesecake and
they got dunkaroo's cookie dough
course they got limited it's for a
limited time they got dunkaroo's cookie
though that's amazing i mean even that
if you're not buying it off that i don't
know i don't know what the hell i need i
can tell you that they got steak and
shrimp and cheddar wonderburgers and all
that soy food and hibachi sweet stuff
and all i can tell you that but if
you're not getting it for dunkaroo
flavored cookie dough we can't help you
what do you want me to say to you who
else is doing that you're you're
ridiculous it's 72 cheaper than any
restaurant meal of the same quality on
average over 65 per month you save when
you order hello fresh instead of going
to the grocery store that's more money
to put toward those other 2022 goals you
have of yours now that's all you got to
do and the offer that we give you it's
getting insane now it's just
progressively gone up and it's the meals
are going up
the free meals are rocketing listen to
this go to hellofresh.com
slash hey babe 16
and use code hey babes 16 for up to
[Music]
three free gifts oh my god dude what do
you want i mean seriously who's the ceo
of hellofresh santa santa
16 free meals
dot com slash hey vape 16 use code hey
babe 16. you get 16 free meals i mean if
again
i don't i can't help you if you're not
going to go do this i can't what do we
call hellofresh
america's number one meal okay
all right listen amazon music i mean is
there any is there anything else what
does amazon not do let's do it let's do
an app i understand but here there's
paid and there's free and listen to what
you get with the free you're listening
to this show it's safe to say you love
podcasts well there's a ton of podcasts
on amazon music over 10 million free
podcast episodes we're one of them yeah
you can listen to the hilarious podcast
smart less maybe they're hilarious are
they hilar as hilarious that's probably
not yeah breathtaking true crime podcast
doctor death miracle man yes which
sounds like doctor quinn medicine not
just a podcast though they have
thousands of music stations yeah and top
playlists to stream for free and you can
go hands-free with the lexus you can use
your your hands to do a laptop
alexa i meant to say alexa i said elec i
have a let because i don't have amazon
music i have alexis which is the bs
version so with amazon music you get
alexa which is the one you want now if
you've never tried amazon music
unlimited now's a great time for a
limited time only new customers can try
amazon music unlimited for free for
three months no credit card required all
you got to do is go to amazon.com hey
babe that's amazon.com hey babe to try
amazon's music unlimited free for three
months amazon.com hey babe renews
automatically cancel any time terms
apply
can you google uh ass
job no not as job
s implants us job uh uh uh uh ass
implant gone wrong yeah yeah sure this
is what they're filled with if you
wanted to buttock augmentation but by
the way how funny is the word buttocks
is it not one of the best funniest most
funniest words there's not more people
in this world
tweet us right now at jebepod or email
the pod heybaypod at gmail.com if your
last name or you know a person's last
name is buttock oh you think someone's
name is botox i mean if there's a guy
named dick buttkiss there has to be
somebody there
earl buttock yeah yeah and buttock is
fun but buttock is funnier buttock is
hilarious what
what word do you think is funny than
buttock buttock what word is funnier
than butthole
my buttock
so funny because it sounds formal it
sounds it is it's like what the doctor
says like uh i did you'll feel some
pressure on your right but on your right
buttock
brazil has an over
two six-pack
over mexico and fourth place finisher
india
what does that mean at two six pounds
but
india is in fourth place for butt
implants
wait wait wait oh brazil i thought
brazil had i thought they were natural
in brazil i thought that was a i thought
that was a physical attribute that was
uh that was basically inherent to
brazilians two things you need to know
these are facts any of our fans in
brazil will will say this two things you
need to know
everybody's got butt implants everybody
has aids that's what you got to know
about brazil man yeah
that's what it is but implant gone wrong
had an aids eighth surgery gone wrong
oh my god oh my god i mean
the thing is is like oh my god
look at the one in the blue look at that
look at the blue on the right oh my god
it's like uh
i i don't understand what that is it
looks like a bicep
yeah yeah that it's like two
circular
orbs
oh look at that one yeah with the red
yes what happened there see that's what
i'm saying if you sit down too hard
if you if you sit down too hard
you can't have god forbid you're on a
plane with fresh buttock implants and
you hit a little turbulence you're gonna
pop
oh holy geez oh my god if i saw this it
would scare me from getting it oh look
at that oh that one that this picture
right here that pimp can you post black
market but i i don't know if i can post
that one black market butt injection
butt injections that looks like what my
butt looks like right now
yeah you got black market butt injection
but i got black market butt injection
but by the way speaking of black markets
1989 is a show i've been watching
on hulu i don't know if it's on hulu but
i've been watching hulu
um uh
on you know i have hulu live tv uh oh
that's that's why i watched my cable
there's a show 1989 do you know the
world that we're living in 2021 or if
you're listening to this in 2022 or
maybe listen to this in 2027 know yeah
yeah yeah hold on hold on imagine
because it might happen for real that
someone's listening to this in the year
3005.
if this is 3005
a thousand years from now yeah wait a
minute what's your guys message to the
future
follow me on insta it's volcano dot yeah
volcano on all socials yep
yeah my uh yeah my um
someone's running my account for a
thousand years past posthumously yes
though so so yeah but that kind of so if
you're listening guys yeah if you're
listening 1999 1989 direct correlation
to the world we're living in right now
in 1989
was the um
crux of everything started because 1989
a couple of big things happened okay you
ready for this 1999
the type of journalism we have right now
the the pop sensational journalism
started in 1989 with the more deployment
show maury palmer show was the first
show to start talking about because it
used to be pre-1999 used to just be the
news there was no clickbait there was no
clickbait but the clickbait they found
the more republican
impetus of clickbait click impetus of
clickbait which is the name of our new
band impetus of clickbait come see us
we'll be in chicago it's rolls off the
tongue rolls off the tongue will also be
impetus of clickbait will also be
december 26th or 31st will be in texas
missouri and ohio cincinnati uh new
year's eve impetus of clickbait christa
stefano salvo
listen i mean yeah actually texas what's
let's come out i mean we are i mean
yeehaw texas you're up first december 26
27 28 dallas houston yeah we're doing a
whole texas tour we're gonna be in
i want you to come with spurs bring tim
tim duncan is coming to the san antonio
show we've got conf
if you come to the texas show with a six
shooter pistol we'll let you shoot it
100 you could shoot out you could shoot
me on stage i don't care st louis
missouri at the factory i mean you're
gonna come uh
yeah bring your arch that what's famous
to arch bring uh bring dr scholl's foot
in search before make sure your archers
are that's correct and then cincinnati
at the taft theater columbia we're doing
road trips too we're driving all around
texas but driving all around ohio
columbus which is even more fun we're
going to have a a little uh complicated
december 30th at the palace theater
we're going to be in columbus ohio i
love columbus you go down to north high
street there's some good shopping down
there you think i don't know i love that
little toy store down there how about
this how about this i know in columbus
ohio i bought my daughter um you were
with me when i bought that red leather
jacket i was with you
i love that shout out to samson too
that's a really good men's store over
there
columbus you remember the place we ate
on north oh my god the southern food it
was all we're gonna go back there yeah i
did i did a hard talk at search for it
on the internet the other day and i
couldn't locate it but i know it's not
normal
i'll know where it is when we get to the
airport yeah yeah yeah um
soul kicks too shout out showed up shout
out but then cincinnat's
taf theater yeah you guys new year's eve
here's what i think we should do and i
really think we should do this if the
taf theater sells out and i'm being
serial
if the taf theater sells out on new
year's eve
it'll be over
by like 9
9 30.
i think that we tell everyone let's go
party here and we frickin go party with
everybody let's do it whoever can get in
get in but we will be there and we'll
just do an old-fashioned like rock'em
sock on new year's eve i'm down for that
um
so let's do that and you only and you
only will know
where we're going if you come to the
show
correct yeah but but i i mean that if it
sells out i would i normally wouldn't do
that
but i'm feeling wild right now let's do
it let's do it i feel like if cincinnati
sells out we will we will have a place
ready to go
a big space and we'll just tell people
we're going here and whoever can get and
get in and we're going to just go we'll
be on the do like the bar thing where
you get on and then you take the bottle
and you import into people's mouths you
know yeah well maybe not maybe not maybe
not why not i'll film whatever happens
listen i'm willing i'm willing to get
covet for this
um
so how about this so 1989 one
sensational journalism two ready for
this one yes you may know this already
but it's fascinating and people may know
this but it
so
terrorism started in 1989. you want me
to explain
please okay
so
[Laughter]
so we what yes so can can you give me a
little vodka sort of pour in my hand
please please just pour a little bit
you mind no i don't there it is okay how
am i gonna do this without spilling i
don't know if you spill you spill how
about just like i feel good how about
just i feel good cheers to
wait if we keep isis
um next week's christmas episode is
gonna be whoo
these chimneys are gonna be our blaze
and i have to uh bring my family to uh a
light show in newark new jersey so we'll
see what happens um we might take an
uber through a light show you should go
to the um
there's a there's a great thing delilah
would love here at the snug harbor it's
the christmas light show is that
fantastic yeah you walked you it's a
path that you walk and it's it's it's a
lot it's it's like it's really worth the
price of it i will do that because it's
feeling like because i'm already i'm
already i've only had two drinks and i'm
already feeling like it's this is gonna
need to be a night where i walk yeah i
don't know i can drive just call an uber
for a delilah yeah
all right so terrorism here's how it
started yeah so in 1989 the russians had
had uh uh invaded afghanistan okay and
the russians wanted to take over
afghanistan the same way the united
states won't take over afghanistan and
we just recently left so the russians
when the russians invaded afghanistan it
was kind of like a uh
like an extension of the cold war where
the united states backed afghanistan and
russia was russia so it was like still
cold war tactics and we backed
afghanistan the afghani rebels we gave
them weapons and and supplies and all
that and then russia left right and then
when the united states they did the
irish exit they irish
the russians just left one day nighttime
they said so russia irished they said
see russia irish okay and then what
happened was is the united states stayed
in afghanistan
and
were really not nice to the people of
afghanistan according to this
documentary really not nice to the
people of afghanistan and then
within afghan because russia just left
in the united states just left
afghanistan became a very unstable
uh very unstable society and different
factions
started to uh you know build up one of
them being al-qaeda and the united
states chose the afghani to stay with
the afghani rebels and al qaeda was like
almost like a bit of a civil war osama
bin laden and then blah blah 1993 world
trade center bomb then they bombed the
uss cole then 9 11. so that kind of so
that was the that was because we got
involved
of the cold war really at the
afghanistan fight had nothing to do with
us it was russia that wanted to invade
afghanistan because they were pretty
close by in the asia continent and they
wanted their oil but so us getting
involved that's what happened caused a
string but there was terrorism before 89
yeah but not the way it is today not
like the overwhelming threat of it was
today and then the third one knight
saying now what we're seeing today is
the whole idea of a fun cartoon
the simpsons came out in 1989 and before
that before that any cartoon you ever
saw was whitewash vanilla yes bs
and it came and when they and and and
also in 1989 the little mermaid came out
and disney was i think maybe fox had
married with children too was like
married with children so fox was
struggling big time they were losing
money hand over fist but they came out
with married with children and the
simpsons saved the network and in the
beginning the simpsons was so
uh out of bounds that schools and george
bush would say president bush at the
time would say do not watch the simpsons
it's horrible yeah everybody hated this
i had a i had
t-shirt right if you went down to the
boardwalk that all you could win was
simpsons merchandise it was everywhere
so
so that was but that was when it was
also tim burton's batman i think that
tim burton's i was gonna say was it
really how crazy i'm remembering this
off the dome i literally was gonna say
batman and the simpsons the the modern
day the the the reason why marvel movies
today thor and iron man even exist is
because of michael keaton's 1990 batman
and jack nicholson's the joker yeah jack
nicholson was a world renowned actress
nobody it would be a step down at 1989
to do a a comic book show right a comic
book movie but jack nichols said i like
this part of the joker which in the
beginning only had five lines
wow the joker was not supposed to be a
heavy part and jack nicholson used to
get pissed and yell at tim burton
because he was like i'm missing the
lakers game for this [ __ ] i heard
that i think i might have heard that did
you watch 1989 no oh i'm just
remembering because i i used to wear the
batman medallion do you i still have it
you know michael keaton got plucked from
to do that movie from doing stand-up to
do his first move from he was a stand-up
comic michael keaton was a regular
stand-up comic like uri right and then
got i think in his first movie he was oh
he did like mr mom mr mom was the big
one yeah yeah yeah i also said seinfeld
started in that year it did it started
in nineteen i haven't well i'm only on
episode three of the series 1989 so i
will see seinfeld eventually uh who
still hasn't texted me back from when he
texted me in april of 2020. um
did i ever tell you that you did i told
and i said it on the pot i think i don't
know i don't know if you said it on the
pod so on the i'll tell another pie yeah
so
out of nowhere in april of 2020 the
beginning of the pandemic i love this
story okay this is every comic stream
okay in the beginning of the panda
i'm sitting there i get a call for a 917
number i see who the [ __ ] is this well
you gave away three digits what can you
do
it's the prefix for everything yeah so i
get it i love you pimp i get so i get a
call i feel like this i see you know
what i'll pick it up what the hell i'm
not doing anything it's covered i'm
quarantined yeah so i pick it up
and
it goes hey can i speak to chris please
i say answers chris he goes it's jerry i
said okay i said who is this because it
sounds like he didn't say seinfeld i
sort of got to go well here he is what
happened he goes it's jerry and i said
okay i thought it was literally
somebody one of any one of our comic
friends do an impersonation like jerry
garcia like there was jerry garcia i
thought it was jerry i was like hello
it's chris
so i say so i say i say i say he goes
hey it's jerry i said
okay who is this and then he goes jerry
i said who is this seriously and he goes
it's jerry seinfeld
i said okay it's not jerry seinfeld who
is it he goes i got your number from
colin quinn this is jerry seinfeld okay
and i said oh my god wow yeah so then i
immediately put it on speaker because
jasmine and my whole family were there
and i muted i said it's jerry's seinfeld
everyone god so then he proceeds to tell
me that he saw my skit online youtube
thing 911. i know i posted that one i
posted that one and said this is as good
as stand-up comedy against
he said he's thank you he said um
christopher was not alive and story so
he says he says to me yeah my son showed
me this he goes and uh i just think that
it you know all these compliments and
then i said thank you so much he goes
listen when the world picks back up
let's go get coffee i said amazing he
goes in a car in a car no he said he
doesn't have that [ __ ] he said if he had
still had that show he put me on it he
said that to me he said but i don't have
that show he said but we could just get
coffee he said that swear to god
i want to go on that show so bad so then
he says to me then he says to me he says
listen and in the meantime you know he
goes look
at any moment you know
you know he said here's the thing he
goes he was so nice and actually humble
he goes look you know i've been around a
long time in comedy he goes i know
sometimes it's very easy to not know if
you're going the right direction in your
career or you know am i making mistakes
doing this to and then it goes just
think of this call as a little sign to
say you're going the right way seinfeld
whoa
somebody's very quick somebody's very
quick off the kettle
i love it he said a little sign up felt
nice joke he said to say that you're
going the right way so that's very sweet
i really you know it really i was like
oh that this is really awesome like that
is i mean if you're going to get a sign
you got to sign from scientists yeah if
you're going to have a sign make it a
failed yeah
so he
he
then says to me if at any also you're
working on jokes you know you got we all
got nothing but time is sitting right
now everything shut down if you ever
have jokes do me a favor he goes i love
writing jokes i love he goes any joke
you have text it to me and we'll i'll
we'll we'll workshop it together
i said
oh
m f g yeah oh my god jasmine my
girlfriend hold this
heard this whole thing so i'm not lying
because she's she ain't gonna lie nah i
heard
because you know there might be like
you're making up i'm not making it up
jasmine heard it did i record it no
but
jasmine heard it
and she's my witness
and she goes i'll be the chicago theater
march 12th
chaos so so she goes so so
so seinfeld says text me any joke you
want ever
no problem
i waited on the he called me at about
1pm as soon as he hung up the second he
hang up i would have texted him why'd
the chicken cross the road
literally as soon as i hung up the phone
i was ecstatic couldn't believe it i
would have done an array of breakdance
moves i need to go i know i need to go
for a walk
unbelievable i go i i said i gotta start
writing jokes i start writing jokes i
wrote three jokes and that's twenty i
waited like it was like texting a hot
chick i waited 24 hours just
so thirsty
texted him a new bit that i wrote it has
been left on red since april of 2020 it
is now december of 2021 i have gotten no
response wow and you know what i deserve
it because the joke sucked did it would
you oh do you have the i should oh i got
a new foam
oh so you have his number you know
because you know what i think it was i
think it wasn't it was april of 2020. i
think it was like a wuhan
type of bit uh maybe he was like don't
do this and i blew it and i blew it and
then i wouldn't i would have sent him
like a joke about it i would have sent
him a joke about like a skittle i ruined
it or you know a joke about you know
like traffic i have to live with that i
really yeah i i fully i fully remember
knowing you you send them like an isis
joke i was i was an idiot okay no joke
i've been using this every day i'm not
kidding around go ahead
liquid iv okay i'm telling you right now
it's delicious they sent us samples to
begin with i re-upped and ordered
already i've been given liquid iv as
gifts
so it's all it is and they have great
flavors they have guava watermelon acai
they have all these great favorite
strawberry and i dump a packet into my
what i do is i take a 40-ounce jug with
me everywhere okay i dump a packet and
they say it's on the back of it they say
you get three times as much hydration
like it's it's like equivalent drinking
three water bottles when you add in the
liquid iv and i feel great and when i'm
drinking it i feel like
i'm i swear to god because i get
headaches i don't know if you know this
yeah i get headaches and it's always
from dehydration and a lot of times when
i first wake up so i leave that by the
bedside and over the course of the night
i drink a full 40 ounce with a liquid iv
in it and i wake up my headaches have
gone away i'm just telling my personal
experience yes i mean dude and the
liquid iv oh i've been using them pimp
uses them every time i get hung over i
use them especially with flu season
coming in you need all the vitamins you
can get liquid iv is the best it's made
with clean ingredients non-gmo vegan
free of gluten dairy and soy and all
that stuff it's got vitamin c it's got
potassium whatever the hell you want you
got the potassium i'm telling you get a
sweet discount with us you're going to
get 25 off anything you order when you
get better hydration today using promo
code hey babe at liquid
iv.com that's liquid iv.com use the code
hey babe 25 off whatever the hell you
want to order
and flavors nationwide at walmart
it's true it's absolutely true and and
just one last thing because not a lot of
companies do this they're donating four
million servings of it in response to
covert 19. so give it up for liquid i
think give it up
babe i got some stan socks in the mail i
already own about 10 pair me too they
sent me four new pairs that i didn't
have i'm not wearing them right now i
almost put them on but stan socks are my
absolutely favorite thing too
they sent these new ones they're like um
these they were orange they're like soup
like like flex like uh sport type ones
that are no show ankle yeah my issue
with no show ankle on every brand i've
ever tried is they do not stay up they
they go into my shoe no matter what i
tell you the only socks i have that are
no show angle that stay up our stance i
buy them by the three pack i bought like
four of them i have 12 they just sent me
some new ones they're getting better and
better and they got all types of designs
they got harry potter batman the goonies
etc baseball teams basketball teams
whatever the hell i have steelers i have
biggie smalls i have david bowie i have
fresh prince
i used to have ones that were grand my
mom larry johnson when he used to
because i had grandmama stan socks i
love stance they're the best um and uh
their pal represents a radical
reinvention of socks t-shirts and more
with a sharp focus on comfort quality
and creativity stance brings an a
typical aesthetic alongside some of pop
culture's hottest collaborators for the
ultimate in style and self-expression
because everything you wear should be a
direct extension of who you are and how
you feel baby go get some stance of
power right now and you're going to get
a sweet discount if you just go to
stance.com and pick out whatever styles
you like that's all you got to do is go
to stance.com pick out whatever the hell
you like and they're going to they're
going to take care of you enjoy the
color and comfort of a life less
ordinary withstand oh enjoy yes yes
stance.com
and then okay you're right this is all
in the same day yeah okay so jerry
seinfeld everybody i mean he's like it's
like if you say jerry sampled your
favorite comedian it's fine but it's
like saying michael jordan's your
favorite player it's just the cream of
the crop it's like of course it's like
you you gotta eliminate the top 25 sides
of basketball player besides michael
jordan everybody
my favorite comedian is bill burr
so i'm riveting in in this i like
literally i'm like i'm still like my you
know adrenaline i got a hard-on it's
crazy he's also my fave
about three hours later i get a random
text out of nowhere random text hey hope
you don't mind i got your number this is
bill burr love the 911 skit
i was like you didn't know burp prior
not really
i said you didn't know richard pryor
no i didn't know it's wordplay today
with me i didn't know richard pryor i
didn't know i was trying to think of but
i didn't know well you know bill you
didn't know bill prior
damn it who's another pr i can't think
of anything i don't know oh
vincent price no i don't know prior
prior is there another prior now is
there another prior on earth that's
famous that's notable not that i could
think of
famous people prior no no i don't know
any of those people cactus prior charles
i don't know texas humorous well there's
hundreds but i don't know any of them
snooki pryor
uh
wait so i didn't realize you didn't
really like kind of know him i remember
when i met him finally for the first
time and everything i was like this is
unbelievable he's the nicest dude in the
world and even now we're like friends
friendly we text and stuff like that
i've you know every once while i see him
but i never like
i never have a cop to it i'm just like
hey what's up
but the reason why i bring it up is
because jerry seinfeld talked to me
about it right unbelievable then a
couple hours later whatever day was that
1989 no but
then a few hours after that i get a dm
which i never gotten before at all from
someone who
i don't know where they were from where
they lived they said hey great job on
this 911 skit it plays right into the
isis handbook i hope you and your family
get decapitated by the muh by the to the
muhajin which was interesting and the
reason i'm bringing up is because the
muhajin muha jadin were is the uh was
the fighting force that the united
states backed in 1989 so i remember
being like this is crazy seinfeld loved
it burr loved it and now somebody else
is telling me it's playing right into
the isis handbook but in what way does
your joke play story play into the isis
hand i have no idea i didn't i don't
know i said listen burn seinfeld love to
go [ __ ] yourself yeah you know that
person probably walks around and
everything they think plays into the
handbook they think it's just that type
of person i mean they wake up but if
zeiss's handbook this is handbook that i
don't even know if isis has a handbook
or a playbook i don't know what they do
i mean if they had it wouldn't we have
our hands on it by now you ever seen a
show on netflix called the dictators
playbook no that's the thing with
companies like netflix or anything but
that when people get outraged at it's
like people get mad at comedy specials
and they're like oh this that but then
netflix has a show called the dictators
playbook where they tell you episode by
episode frame by frame how the dictators
became the dictators right so that's
okay yeah netflix is okay to do the
dictators playbook but if god forbid a
comedian makes a joke right god forbid
chappelle says anything funny but the
dictator's handbook is fine women
reportedly caught breastfeeding cat on
delta airlines flight that was pimp said
you get your drunk risks let's make a
shift he said this is hey babe yeah
remember we are we are very pro lgbtq
i mean we are with you listen we are
with you uh you
know we're not looking to get into that
conversation
women reportedly caught breastfeeding
cat on delta airlines flight so it's
nice that yeah hey listen sometimes a
[ __ ] needs some titties
just like daddy's back and i'm back
i'll text you out right now
wow i mean a cat sucking on a titty for
milk it's
interesting how about this reality tv
star says she makes 50 000 a week by
selling her farts in a jar holy [ __ ]
what is going on
what is going on would you buy a fart in
a jar no
i once saw it on ebay a bit and it was
high it was air from the room of elon
gonzalez the night he got captured
how much and it was
and then they got taken down you might
be able to google it let's read what
this woman says about this though who is
she i okay her name is stephanie maddow
okay she said i thought farts were super
niche but also something fun quirky and
different
i don't like this that see because i
think somebody sold an nft of their fart
for like money listen to that sentence
and just know right now we're doomed
doomed we're doomed right now if you're
selling nfts of your farts
what is going on
i don't get it so who how does she how
much are they how do you buy it let's
buy one and open it on the pod
can you google it by far in the jar can
we get together it's like a thousand
dollars
what i could do a thousand a jar oh this
that's a discounted price it says oh if
i saw her on the street i would knock
the fart out of him you ever liked
anyone enough to want it
no i don't even know where they are i
wouldn't i'm just doing this because
he'll smell it and then i'll react
i'm not going near it how does she know
it keeps but let me ask you questions go
down go down go down a little bit pimpy
can you scroll down so look so she go a
little bit more she's got jaws all over
the apartment because see she's hot
like does the fact that she puts farts
in a jar and make her not look hot or
just thinking about the fart when you
see her or used to attract everything
about her could take a walk for me yeah
would you monetize a fart she's a pretty
girl but like i don't care
it's really with the fart it's who you
are on the inside
good
boy we should lube up with vodka more
often um
i'm legitimately drunk i feel good the
jowls the balls on this girl to sell a
thousand air but she's she's got just
the house littered with mason jars
because if one comes and she doesn't
catch it she loses
she loses a c note is it
is it c note a thousand or something
speaking of mason jars you know what
i've been doing she loses a band what's
the band
band to make you dance bands are like
you dance oh it's a hundred see there's
a hundred she uses ten what's a band
ten c notes bands that make you dance
yeah yeah i got that right she loses a
band if she fought into the air dude
this is the new common core math in
public schools right now they're like
they're like kevin left the house with a
rack he had to pay two bands
how much how many c notes does kevin
have left after paying two bands for a
quarter ounce when he left the house
with a rat yeah
right
this is it this is it this is the new
business model
my
business bed
wait what are we saying now mason jars
yeah so can we buy it should we spend
should we crowdsource this should we
spend a thousand dollars a christmas
gift to the fans should we spend a
thousand dollars golfer but you open
that mason jar and there's no smell in
there we have to have we have to i will
take a small claims andrew cuomo just
had to give back 5.1 million dollars of
his pandemic book money we could spend a
g on a far jar
do you want to spend that much money it
feels wasteful
how about we contact her because we're
giving her a promotion right now since
what's her instagram dare we ask her to
send us a free fart for all the
promotions she's getting she got 20 000
views on the vid what's what's her ig
yeah fart girl stephanie maddow
well don't get yeah here it is
fart girl 260 okay 270 000. from 90 day
fiance this is amazing i love this she's
just blasting ass into a jar she lives
in new york oh look wait listen we see
on the street we get a phone for free
wait why don't you just have her come in
and fart and stupid hello
she can come here and do the
manufacturing right here
pimpy can we dm that's it called
chipotle called chapat um speaking of
farts i've been making cold oatmeal
every night i want to start cooking for
you guys yeah does she have a nice voice
she farts in the drawer
take someone you'd buy a jar for a fart
jar
this is wild there is no shame anymore i
guess god bless if you're if you're
getting home down payments with with
with guests but like what about your
parents and stuff like are they like
well how's your daughter the holidays
come around she's making money don't
have everything she's doing well she's
doing well she's doing well so she was
on that show yeah she was on the show so
what'd she do now for cash what's she
not for work what's she doing now for
work well well i'm glad you asked i'm
glad yes pester mashed potatoes so she's
blessing her own thoughts into her jaws
stealing them and telling them for a
thousand a clip yeah it's better than
her doing porn and hey listen your
father's a surgeon my daughter's making
more than she's and the main thing is
she's vaccinated yeah that's right um
so
so how does she know a fart is some of
them don't aren't not as bad as others
what if she would she blast into a mason
and then that thing arrives and there's
nothing in there that means technically
you can't prove if she's just not
mailing mason jars yeah because you know
what it
has is fart spray how do you know it's
an authentic that's this isn't out is
there a certificate of water what's her
name what's her name stephanie we're on
to you steph uh stefan k amato
s-t-e-p-a-n-k-a-m-a
do it again not even close s-t-e
p-a-n stephanie motto
instagram i'm gonna pay you a thousand
dollars but what i want to prove it's
you is not a fart in a jar but a
sharpener jar
that's what i want whoa
that's usually fourteen hundred yeah
yeah you're asking for a four that's
what i'll pay and then you'll get
promotion yeah i mean it's it is one
step from her selling us a log yeah yeah
that's great
yeah stephanie uh
there's a flash sale on you log from
stephanie yeah why not just it's a step
away from selling your extra draw you'll
get my money what are we doing here it's
[ __ ]
we just gave her we just made it like 80
thousand dollars how about this i want
to just read something i screenshot this
because i like to live i like to do
things that help me out you know things
you know what a stoic is
someone's the word stoic stoic s-t-o-i-c
or like stoicism i i i believe i know
what stoic is so like a stoic stoicism
like these are people like they lived
like ancient greece like the whole
stoicism thing was like basically like
it's just like ways to like live
like your life right like stoicism is
greek school of philosophy founded at
athens by xeno of sidium
school taught the virtue that the
highest good is based on knowledge the
wise live in harmony with the divine
reason that governs nature and are
indifferent to the vistatides of fortune
and pleasure and and for of fortune and
to pleasure and pain okay i gotta be
honest you read the explanation i have
no more information in my head than i
did before you read it so let me tell
you i screenshot this because what i've
been doing is trying i've been uh
following an instagram account called
stoic daily and five stoic lessons from
seneca who was a greek philosopher and i
grew up on seneca avenue and ridgewood
queen
it's a seinfeld that's a seinfeld sign
for a moment and maybe the people at hay
babe can take this with them and it'll
help them in life tell me right now i
want to know these principles right now
number one yeah we suffer more in
imagination than in reality 100 percent
true there's nothing i can do about it
how true is that that sums up my life
more than anything you could say to me i
walk around all the time we all do i
walk around thinking about worst case
scenarios and projecting my fears as if
they're realities in the current moment
i do it all the time i try my best to
correct it it's the way i'm hardwired
because the reality is for you right now
sales you got banging hair we're
drinking vodka so yeah we're gonna have
a little fun tonight that's true that's
what it is that's true the reality is
right now we're having a damn good time
we're having a dance
three dear friends drinking and making
entertainment and having some laughs
right now with with the suggestions
podcast we're making about two farts in
a jar an episode that's right so
so that's the yeah i mean can we can you
share your farts and how much we if you
charge your farts we're lucky if we get
a 99 cents a fart
you'd have to fart a thousand times to
get stephanie's right what would you pay
for a collective i'm talking about me
sal volcano and mike lavin the homeless
person three of us fought in a jar what
would you pay for that a triple four
what would you pay could we beat them
okay so that's number one by the way
babes merch will be available within
like a week or two i swear to god i'm
not making a joke i have spent about 20
hours that you don't know about working
on my solo merch hey bay merch and taste
buds merch and there is gonna be some
tupperware [ __ ] coming out yes and it's
awesome we modeled it after an old
tupperware ad it's so cool you gotta get
and we're gonna have it are we having
time for people to buy for christmas
they're pushing it but because of coves
and limited supplies it might do jam but
it's time for valentine's day 100 but
we're trying to push it in time for
christmas and trying to push it the
first people that will will get any of
our merch any of we're trying to push it
for the week of of the the tour between
christmas and new year's for texas st
lewis and cincinnati they will have in
ohio they will have the if we get it
done in time they will have the first
run at merch out of anybody dude number
one so that's why even more to go to the
tickets go salvagano salvocanocomedy.com
christycommy.com december 26 31st hey
babe we're coming on the road it's going
to be amazing co-headlining doing stand
up yes okay so number two oh associate
only with people who improve you
okay so right now that's amazing
we're associating right now only people
here improve me right right but don't be
out there and associating with people
who don't approve you i love it i love
it number three that's so true number
three the this is a big one the greatest
remedy for anger is delay yeah so
meaning when you're angry cool it
cool off baby cooler heads prevail the
greatest
for anger greatest remedy for anger is
delay so far this is amazing number four
value your time
more than your possessions
your time is worth more a lot of people
just factor in money
factor in time make time and money equal
babes and i guarantee you you will be
happy
five
the most important rule
that i've ever read of anything in my
life no white hat no way it's a labor
day no white after labor day number five
the reason why i screenshotted this what
seneca said and he said this and then
allegedly died because of how powerful
and amazing this fifth rule was the
reason why screenshots
genuinely in my heart has changed my
life like that's why i screamed at this
i read this to say
the number fifth thing that seneca wrote
upon dying was this has been hay baby
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
[Music]
it's coming up december 26th to the 31st
we will be in texas missouri and ohio go
get your tickets end the year with us
co-headlining doing stand-up comedy it's
going to be fun it's going to be great
go to savile counter comedy.com or
christiecomedy.com it's going to be
great
and then also babe also babe you know
what i just put on sale today what's
that oh actually yesterday is i'm coming
to chicago i'm doing the chicago
theater use the pre-sale code chaos the
pre-sale is happening right now at
christiecomedy.com the chicago theater
march 12th baby okay and here we go for
me i gotta call out two dates san diego
on january 21st at the magnolia theater
and los angeles january 22nd at the
wilton theater i have not headlined in
los angeles yet it's gonna be a real
special show there'll be some surprise
guests there from the la area it's gonna
be a lot of fun go see that one last
thing to call out yeah we're both
playing the agora theater in cleveland
oh my god what are you going to be there
i'm going to be there on january 16th
babe yes and i'm going to be there in
march yes
so uh yes
60 days after me i'm going to leave you
a joint underneath one of the seats i'm
going to tape it to one of these come to
both shows at the agora theater if you
don't i'll kill your loved ones